So just in terms of relating it to trading,
this is a debate I've had with
economist and macro guys for a long time,
women traders that use fundamentals.
I personally don't.
I've never used
financial news or anything like that for my trading,
just purely chart based.
So that works for me.
So for me, I,
I, I don't need it.
Others may. So odds of lies
probably somewhere in the middle.
Yeah. I think what the question was alluding to
there was more like the actual media,
you know, like CNBC.
Yeah, that's the only one that comes to mind.
But like these news channels basically,
right, who were reporting the financial news,
are they reliable?
And I would say they're not.
They're just fair mongrels.
You like cryptos,
cryptos going down.
They always report that
cryptos like amazingly doing well when it's at the top.
And they always report
like it's absolutely doomed when it's at the bottom
when they're the
complete opposite and inverse ways of looking at it,
if that makes sense.
Yeah, no, I completely agree.